Elizabeth smarts father says there is
something he has to talk about 17 years
after his daughter's kidnapping and
miraculous rescue yet smart is revealing
how he struggled to come out as gay his
first Network TV interview about his
sexuality his story was first reported
back in August but this is the first
time that he's talking about it publicly
the 64 year old man who was married to
his former wife Louis for 34 years and
the father of six children told us how
difficult it was to reconcile his faith
with his feelings during the course of
my life you know I've certainly found
you know men to be attractive I was
taught that that was not acceptable that
that was something that you were a
deviant you were a bad person if you
thought those things but you know you're
not a deviant head no no but that was
what I was brought up to believe I never
wanted to identify as being gay I never
wanted that to be part of me mm-hmm why
would God give this to me why would I
have to endure this in life how did you
try to fix it I went to therapists I
went to my church leaders I mean I
literally called my bishop up one
morning and I said you know I feel like
I've stabbed Louis in the heart and I
went to my other church leader and I
said to him so am i gay am i gay and he
said to me I don't think so he said you
know there's this spectrum and it's
fluid within this spectrum when he said
I don't think you're gay did you feel
relieved at hearing that you're thinking
okay maybe I'm not yes I was praying
that I was not I didn't want to believe
that I was
how do you get how do you cure being gay
there is no cure and for all of those
out there that are struggling in this
same spot there is no cure but that's
part of why you're speaking yes it is it
is the reason why I'm speaking this is
absolutely not a choice and I wish my
wife knew that I wish that worth
anything
he is so concerned it is I have to say
very powerful even we all walked out of
there your heart just opens up to him
because can you imagine living your
whole life not being able to be who you
are he's very very concerned about his
ex-wife Louis because the last thing he
wants is hurt her and certainly not hurt
his family but he said he could just no
longer live this way you know people
would say he had you have a problem he
goes you know what my problem was I was
a gay man trying to be straight yeah
that was my problem yeah now you know he
wants to speak out to help others
because he said it really was torturous
for him and imagine what it was like
when Elizabeth Smart disappeared he was
front and center the the public phase he
was worried about that then there was a
lot going on so we will continue our
conversation tomorrow thankful thankful
that he thinks he needs a cure kind of
the guilt the grief and then relief
ultimately he's not the only one from
that generation oh I know I know I
believe that too Tony you'll see more of
our conversation with Edie smart
tomorrow
he'll talk about the difficult process
of coming out to his family